[Musik]
hallo mein name ist heute auf dem handy
irgendwie durch junge die steuerung muss
man sich noch ein bisschen gewöhnen hier
ist jetzt irgendwie so komisch klinge
springen da muss alles klar
was habe ich denn falsch gemacht ich bin
noch ganz normal einfach da runter
gefahren und habe dann gebetet wird
passiert genauso wie jetzt bisher man so
aber egal wir wissen jetzt was ihr ziel
genau passiert das heißt wir gehen hier
und jetzt auf neue kollegen
kollegah alles klar mein bein ist
einfach weg ist in ordnung
ach so alles klar in ordnung fiel dem
ich lebe noch ihr kollege spring das
danke okay jetzt hier in die höhle aber
ganz schnell wieder zurück kohle ja ja
auch okay weiter gehts hier unten lang
jetzt bin ich irgendwie hob ballack
genau hier drüber und
und gerade das war nur mit einem halben
bein und einem arm aber egal ich hasse
das
diese steht da loading alter new level
of gentlemen und auch die heilige jetzt
hier schön den weg runter hier alles
klappt schon wieder beim verleihen ist
okay kollege alles in ordnung die scilly
ja scheiße was soll ich dazu sagen
kollegen was eine scheiße mann das ist
dass wir hier nochmal machen
mein helm ist auch schon wieder weg auf
die heilige nein so schön hier hoch und
jetzt was ist das denn für ein
schwachsinn
es funktioniert nicht schon wieder fällt
erst mal scheißegal damit die sache mit
dem business school
ok coming soon kam ich zu 100 dann immer
alles endete dann können wir einfach
wieso gibt es in dem spiel noch nichts
von mama business geile 25
ein wunderschöner sonnenuntergang in
riesiger papier das ist schon mal klar
dass jetzt hier überspringen muss hier
auch autobahnen
dann spiele ist im app store das heißt
jeder vierjährige kann sich das
runterladen
ganz langsam hierüber bremsen so jetzt
ab was ist er okay alles klar was
passiert denn wenn ich hier einfach mal
daran wie wieso war das klare sieht auf
jeden fall sehr gesund aus wie el adly
com luca ich muss mir jetzt drin sein
soll hier drauf stehen bleiben das ist
so schwer da das gleichgewicht sobald
das ist nicht aber ich dachte ich jetzt
geschafft aber ich glaube das ist nicht
euer gott mein herz es ist unmöglich da
das gleichgewicht zu halten ich dachte
so jetzt jetzt so weiter geht es hier
schon wieder mal wenn ich diese scheiße
dem verpacken alles klar ist tom luca
ich glaub an dich du bist mein held in
happy meals wenn du das nicht schaffst
dann bist du schön abwarten jetzt sind
sie wieder zusammen jetzt schnell rüber
und jetzt hier den kriege ich noch mein
beines weg in das zu schaffen was ist
sein scheint auch komme ich bitte dich
was kann denn dieser kleinen bomben luca
es kann doch nicht so schwer sein
einfach da gott verdammt ja
wahrscheinlich wenn ich jetzt nicht
schaffe dann ist aber mein komplettes
happy meals leben amara stadt riecht
hier auch keinen zweiten part ich muss
das jetzt schaffen
das kann doch nicht sein das ist doch
nicht schwer ich meine ich muss einfach
jetzt hier über so auch geschafft jetzt
spiele ich da vorne gleich auf diese
schwebende plattform drauf die jetzt
reden wir drüber kommt genau da ist
jetzt stehe ich nämlich genau hier
realisierte dass dieser fall mehr
anzeigen wo ich hin muss hat man hier
genau genau genommen
ich bin ich hier auf die sogenannte